.
Ni hao, Ge.
* Er spricht Mandarin. *
* Treibende elektronische Musik *
Good to see you.
Wow.
Ni hao.
Wir sind jetzt Freunde geworden.
Mein Name ist Pascal Nufer.
Fünf Jahre lang habe ich als
Korrespondent aus China berichtet.
Es war eine spannende,
aber auch zermürbende Zeit,
geprägt von einem ständigen
Katz-und-Maus-Spiel mit den Behörden.
Jetzt will ich dem Land
eine zweite Chance geben.
Ich möchte die Menschen erleben,
nicht den mächtigen Staat.
Ich will mich mit China versöhnen.
* Jubelrufe *
Wow.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
(Frau)
Das ist typisches Schanghai-Wetter.
Ja, sehr typisch, leider.
Das vermisse ich überhaupt nicht.
Seit vier Monaten
bin ich weg aus Schanghai.
Mit meiner Journalistenkollegin Lisa
besuche ich das Quartier,
in dem ich früher gewohnt habe.
Ich bin noch einmal hier,
weil ich versuchen will,
den Chinesen
endlich etwas näher zu kommen.
Wenn du sagst, hier wohnen Chinesen
und viele Ausländer -
mischt sich das denn?
- Nicht sehr.
Es ist hauptsächlich
die Expat-Community unter sich
und die chinesische Community
unter sich.
Und die Kinder auch nicht?
Du hast doch Kinder.
Spielen die nicht
mit den chinesischen ...
Auf dem Spielplatz
oder auf dem Basketballfeld
spielen sie schon miteinander,
aber irgendwie ...
Es ist ganz selten,
dass das mit den Kindern auch klappt,
weil die so
unterschiedliche Stundenpläne haben.
Die chinesischen Kinder
haben ja keine Freizeit.
Klar, die sprachlichen Hürden
sind in China hoch.
Auch die kulturellen.
Und ich war sehr beschäftigt.
Aber Tatsache bleibt:
Es ist mir schwergefallen,
wirklich Freundschaften
mit Chinesen zu schliessen.
Ich habe mich immer gefragt,
ob es an mir
oder an den Chinesen liegt.
Es hat einfach nicht funktioniert.
Deshalb will ich jetzt sehen,
ob es einen Weg gibt,
das besser zu machen.
Ich möchte die Menschen
näher kennenlernen,
mit denen ich in den letzten
fünf Jahren am meisten zu tun hatte.
Ah, du bist schon da?
Unsere ehemalige Haushälterin.
Ich nenne sie Ayi -
übersetzt heisst das Tante.
So nennt man hier alle Frauen,
die diese Arbeit machen.
Hao. Xie, xie.
Mit dem Elektroroller
fährt sie uns voraus
zum Haus ihrer neuen Arbeitgeberin.
Wo ist der Hase?
- Da hinten.
* Sie sprechen chinesisch. *
Da wohnt jetzt auch
unser früherer Familienhase,
den wir leider nicht
in die Schweiz mitnehmen konnten.
Du bist ja ganz nass, Fluffy.
Ich soll dir einen lieben Gruss
von Ada und Enno ausrichten.
Ich habe meinen Kindern versprechen
müssen, Fluffy zu fotografieren.
Sie vermissen ihn.
Aber sonst hat sich meine Familie
in der Schweiz recht gut eingelebt.
Meine beiden Kinder
haben ein vertrauteres Verhältnis
zu Ayi als ich.
Mein Sohn war ein Baby,
meine Tochter sieben,
als sie anfing, sie zu hüten.
* Fröhliche Popmusik *
Sie haben eine Überraschung
für Ayi vorbereitet.
* Die Kinder sprechen chinesisch. *
Das meiste Chinesisch
haben meine Kinder von ihr gelernt.
Danke.
Nicht weinen.
Ayi hat sich gefreut, mir Einblick
in ihr privates Leben zu geben
und sich dabei filmen zu lassen.
Sie will mich übers Wochenende
in ihr Heimatdorf auf dem Land
mitnehmen, zu ihrer Familie.
Erst hat sie mich aber zum Abendessen
in ihr Haus in Schanghai eingeladen.
Das tun Chinesen nur selten.
* Fliessende, elektronische Klänge *
Schanghai gehört
zu den grössten Städten Chinas.
Ayi lebt
ungefähr 1 Std. vom Zentrum entfernt.
Ich weiss, sie hat verschiedene Jobs
und arbeitet viel,
trotzdem bin ich ein wenig erstaunt,
wie schick die Wohnsiedlung ist,
in die wir fahren.
* Sie sprechen chinesisch. *
Vor zwei Jahren
haben sie und ihr Mann
dieses vierstöckige Haus gekauft.
Die beiden leben hier mit ihrem Sohn,
der Schwiegertochter
und der kleinen Enkelin.
Ni hao. Ni hao.
Ni hao wa. Ni hao.
- Ni hao wa.
Der Hausherr
führt mich ins Untergeschoss.
Wow, das ist ja riesig!
Ah, da unten ist ein Billardtisch.
Ayis Mann war von Beruf Schreiner.
Stolz und doch bescheiden
erzählt er mir,
dass er das Innere des Hauses
selbst ausgebaut hat.
Hier hinten ist ...
Wow.
Der Karaokeraum.
Beim Billard erfahre ich dann,
wie der 54-Jährige
sein Glück gemacht hat.
Ich bin 1999
nach Schanghai gekommen.
Damals habe ich ein Haus gekauft,
für etwa 60'000 Euro.
Letztes Jahr konnte ich es
für rund 1 Mio. verkaufen.
Glück gehabt.
* Sanfte Xylofonmusik *
Jetzt hat Ayis Mann
viel Zeit für sein Hobby.
In diesem Haushalt
steht er an den Töpfen.
Ich mag
die unkomplizierte Atmosphäre hier.
Wir werden fürstlich bewirtet,
und mir wird klar,
dass meine frühere Haushälterin
den chinesischen Traum lebt,
den in den letzten Jahrzehnten
Millionen von Chinesen
verwirklicht haben:
Weg aus der Armut auf dem Land,
hinein in die Stadt,
die zumindest den Glücklichen
Wohlstand beschert.
Das ist mehr als 20 Jahre her.
Was war damals dein Traum?
Ich hatte keinen Traum.
Alles, was ich damals wollte,
war, zurück nach Hause zu gehen.
Zu Hause hatten wir nicht viel Geld.
Wir pflanzten Baumwolle an.
Die Arbeit war sehr hart.
Wir hatten nur drei Felder.
Wir verdienten im Jahr vielleicht
gerade mal 150 Euro.
Sehr wenig.
* Nachdenkliche Saxofonmusik *
Am nächsten Tag
lerne ich Ayis Sohn kennen.
Für unseren Ausflug in ihre
Heimatprovinz ist auch Tian dabei,
die mir beim Übersetzen hilft.
Auch die Schwägerin,
die Schwiegertochter
und natürlich die kleine Enkelin
reisen mit.
Ayi, wie oft fährst du nach Hause?
* Tian dolmetscht. *
Nur für das Frühlingsfest.
Dann ist das heute also auch
ein wichtiger Tag für dich?
Ja.
Es ist das erste Mal,
dass die Kleine mitreist.
D.h., dein Vater
sieht das Kind zum ersten Mal?
Ja, ihr Urgrossvater.
Und auch die Urgrossmutter.
Grandgrandparents.
* Sie sprechen chinesisch. *
Grossmama, Grossmama.
- (Lachend) Yes, Grossmama.
Urgrossmama, Urgrossbaba.
- Ah, Urgrossmama. Urgrossbaba.
In Chinesisch haben sie viel genauere
Bezeichnungen in den Familien.
Der Onkel mütterlicherseits
hat nicht dieselbe Bezeichnung
wie der Onkel väterlicherseits.
Das zeigt auch, wie wichtig
die Familie bei den Chinesen ist.
Allerdings: Die jungen Leute
haben viel davon vergessen,
weil die Familien heute
nicht mehr so gross sind.
Wegen der Einkindpolitik
gehen gewisse Bezeichnungen
jetzt verloren.
Mit dem Familienaudi
fahren wir in die Provinz Anhui.
* Treibende Musik *
Ayis Dorf
liegt westlich von Schanghai,
flussaufwärts am Jangtse.
Als Ayi jung war,
dauerte die Reise mit Zug und Schiff
bis zu drei Tage.
Heute sind es noch 5 oder 6 Std.
* Sie spricht chinesisch. *
Ich bin gespannt,
wo Ayi aufgewachsen ist
und ob uns diese Reise
einander näherbringt.
Hallo.
Was macht ihr denn hier?
Es ist eine arme Gegend,
und viele der Hausangestellten
und Arbeiter in Schanghai
kommen aus der Provinz Anhui.
* Nachdenkliche Saxofonklänge *
Ayis Familie wohnt auf einer Insel.
Wir müssen einen Seitenarm
des Jangtse überqueren.
Als Erstes besuchen wir
die Familie von Ayis Mann,
die auf derselben Insel lebt.
Guten Tag. Wie geht es Ihnen?
* Sie sprechen chinesisch. *
Familie hat in China immer Vorrang
vor privaten Freundschaften.
Alle Verwandten, die es irgendwie
einrichten konnten, sind gekommen,
um die Kleine zu bestaunen.
Und ich bilde mir ein, vielleicht
auch ein bisschen meinetwegen.
* Stimmengewirr *
Und dann lernt auch die
Urgrossmutter ihre Urenkelin kennen.
Die ganze Familie zusammen.
Jeder will sie halten.
Sie liebt ihren Grossvater.
Weil der Vater nie da ist.
Komm zu mir.
Ayi erzählt mir,
dass sie nach der Heirat hier
ins Haus ihrer Schwiegereltern zog.
Hier habt ihr
nach der Hochzeit gewohnt?
Ja, das war unser Zimmer.
Okay.
Als unser Sohn drei war,
unterteilten wir das Zimmer.
Wir waren dann nicht mehr
mit den Grosseltern des Kleinen
im selben Raum.
Dieses Möbel
ist von der Familie des Mannes.
Ah, das war die Mitgift.
- Ja.
Wie hast du deinen Mann
kennengelernt?
Wir wurden einander vorgestellt.
Aber wie war das für dich?
War das okay?
* Tian dolmetscht. *
Ich war zufrieden.
Es kommt eben auf die Person an,
ob sie dir tief in die Augen schaut
oder nicht.
Wenn ja, dann ist es okay.
Ihr habt auf derselben Insel gewohnt.
Kanntest du ihn schon?
Das war wegen meiner Cousine.
Sie sah ihn und dann ... war er da.
* Sie sprechen chinesisch. *
Komm!
Kann er uns auch seine Version
der Geschichte erzählen?
Ich hatte zu der Zeit viele Treffen.
Sie beeindruckte mich nicht gross.
Aber sie hatte Geld.
Ja, meine Familie war reicher.
Das stimmt. Ich hatte weniger.
Es ist doch so.
Und wie ist es heute?
So lala.
Ihr hattet Glück. 30 Jahre,
und ihr seid immer noch zusammen.
Ob eine Generation es gut hat,
hängt von den Charaktereigenschaften
der vorherigen Generation ab.
Wenn die ältere Generation
nicht gut erzogen ist,
kann es die nächste auch nicht sein.
Eine hübsche Geschichte,
aber es ist tatsächlich so,
dass auch im modernen China die Ehen
häufig immer noch arrangiert werden.
Es geht weniger
um romantische Gefühle
als um sozialen
und finanziellen Aufstieg.
* Langsame chinesische Musik *
Setz dich hierhin.
Schau, nur die Männer sitzen.
Wenn es zu wenige Plätze gibt,
müssen die Frauen stehen.
Du meinst, wir beide können
froh sein, dass wir sitzen können?
Wir sind Gäste. Wir haben Glück.
Überall, wohin es mich
in China verschlagen hat,
war ich froh,
Tian an meiner Seite zu haben.
Sie übersetzt nicht nur die Sprache,
sie bringt mir seit Jahren
die chinesische Kultur nahe.
* Nachdenkliche Saxofonmusik *
Was ich ohne Hilfe verstehe:
Chinesische Freundschaft
geht in erster Linie durch den Magen.
Es ist kein Zufall,
dass ein chinesischer Gruss heisst:
"Hast du schon gegessen?"
Da, wo Ayi aufgewachsen ist,
stehen viele Häuser leer.
Die Jungen sind abgewandert,
zurückgeblieben
sind fast nur alte Menschen.
Sie leben auch heute noch
v.a. vom Fischfang,
von der Landwirtschaft
und von dem bisschen Baumwolle.
* Nachdenkliche Saxofonmusik *
Schaut mal, die vielen Hunde.
Esst ihr die?
Nein.
- Warum denn so viele?
Obwohl Ayi schon lange weg ist,
kennt man sich noch auf dem Dorf.
* Sie sprechen chinesisch. *
Das ist unsere Tante.
Wir nennen sie einfach Tante.
Seid ihr
zusammen zur Schule gegangen?
Wir waren
im selben Produktionskollektiv.
Ah. Oh.
Also, ich muss los.
Wie lange möchtest du noch arbeiten?
Du müsstest das
ja wahrscheinlich nicht tun.
Du hättest genug Geld.
Ich bin es gewohnt, zu arbeiten.
Nur zu Hause zu bleiben,
wäre für mich anstrengender.
Mein Vater ist auch so.
Wir sind
eine sehr fleissige Familie.
Ja, das weiss ich.
Am nächsten Tag
besuchen wir Ayis Familie.
Ein grosses Haus.
Ni hao. Ni hao.
Hallo.
Das ist mein Vater.
- Ah, dein Vater? Guten Tag.
Sie ist meine Tante, von der Seite
meiner verstorbenen Mutter.
Ah, guten Tag.
Auch in diesem Haus werden wir
natürlich wieder herrlich bekocht.
Bei Tisch stellt sich heraus,
dass der Fluss Jangtse
sowohl für Ayis Familie
als auch für Tian Heimat bedeutet -
auch wenn das jeweilige Zuhause
1'000 km weit
vom anderen entfernt ist.
Gleiche Brücke.
Alle Jangtse-Brücken
sehen gleich aus.
Das ist die bei meinem Zuhause.
Ah, da bist du aufgewachsen?
- Das ist mein Geburtsort.
Aber das sieht alles neu aus.
Das ist alles neu.
Da war die alte Stadt
schon unter Wasser.
Ah, als sie den Staudamm bauten,
wurde die Stadt überschwemmt.
Ja, überschwemmt.
Ich bin eine sog.
Drei-Schluchten-Staudamm-Migrantin.
Ah, du musstest weg,
als sie das Wasser stauten.
Ja. Ich war noch ein Kind.
Damals stellte das niemand infrage
oder dachte viel darüber nach.
Es war ein ruhmreiches Projekt,
und wir unterstützten es.
So sind wir umgezogen.
Ich weiss, dass Tian heute kritischer
über das Jahrhundertbauwerk denkt.
Vor der Kamera aber
bleibt sie diskret.
Gerne hätte ich auch sie
nach Hause begleitet,
aber sie winkt ab.
Ich habe Verständnis dafür,
dass es ihr zu heikel ist,
ihre Arbeit
für einen ausländischen Journalisten
mit ihrer Familiengeschichte
zu vermischen.
(Tian)
Sind das deine Felder da hinten?
(Ayi) Ja, jetzt sind sie verpachtet.
Sie rentieren nicht mehr.
Möchtet ihr irgendwann
hierher zurückkommen?
Ich möchte schon einmal
hierher zurückkommen.
Es ist ruhiger.
Vielleicht, wenn wir älter
und die Kinder richtig gross sind.
Und wenn ich mich
um meinen Vater kümmern muss.
Wir bauen eine Villa -
und einen Fischteich.
Und wir pflanzen Gemüse an.
Zukunftspläne.
* Langsame Klaviermelodie *
Abends bei einem kleinen Bootsausflug
auf dem Seitenfluss des Jangtse
kommen wir noch mal auf die Zukunft
von Ayis Familie zu sprechen.
Jetzt hört es sich etwas anders an.
Die Regierung
plant hier Veränderungen.
Vielleicht reissen sie alles ab.
Man weiss nicht viel.
Wir wissen nicht,
was das für uns heissen würde,
wenn wir jetzt
tatsächlich zurückkommen
und unser Haus renovieren wollten.
Es ist gut, einfach Zeit
miteinander zu verbringen.
Das Vertrauen wächst.
Politik war nie ein Thema mit Ayi.
Aber ich merke einmal mehr,
wie schwierig
es für Chinesen sein kann,
über ihre Zukunft
selbst zu entscheiden.
Am nächsten Tag
treffen wir uns wieder.
Das Filmteam
hat die Nacht im Hotel verbracht,
und wir haben nicht mitbekommen,
dass die Polizei in der Zwischenzeit
bei Ayis Familie
aufgetaucht ist - unseretwegen.
Die Polizei kam zum Haus,
zu ihrem Haus.
(Lisa) Zu welchem Haus?
- Zu ihrem Haus.
Sie hat gefragt, wer das ist.
Ist alles in Ordnung?
- Kein Problem.
Sie sagten,
sie kämen zur Essenszeit wieder.
Sie wollten nur schauen,
ob alles in Ordnung ist.
Wir wollen euch
keine Unannehmlichkeiten bereiten.
Nein, nein, gar nicht.
- Es macht mich nicht nervös.
Ich habe ihnen gesagt,
dass ihr ehrliche Menschen seid.
Es ist schon alles erledigt.
Sie sagten,
es sei nur eine Kontrolle.
Ein Standardablauf.
Die Sache scheint also geklärt.
Zeit, um zum Schluss - was wohl? -
zum Essen eingeladen zu werden.
Eine richtige Einladung
bedeutet in China nämlich,
ins Restaurant zu gehen.
Alles Glückszahlen. 666, 777.
* Stimmengewirr *
Die Verwandten scheinen
Ayis Familie nicht auszugehen.
Wenn man in China nicht zu trinken
und als Mann
nicht zu rauchen versteht,
hat man von der Freundschaft her
gesehen einen schweren Stand.
Oh, jetzt. Oh.
* Sie rufen durcheinander. *
Was ist jetzt zwischen dir und ihm?
- Wir sind jetzt Freunde geworden.
Ja, ja. Ja, so geht das.
- Da hast du's.
* Friedliche chinesische Musik *
(Lisa) This looks funny.
Oh.
- Be careful.
Was ich hier mache,
ist übrigens sehr unchinesisch.
Körperkontakt ist unüblich,
auch unter Freunden.
* Sie sprechen chinesisch. *
Wie waren diese zwei Tage für dich?
Hast du dir das so vorgestellt?
Es war besser,
als ich es mir vorgestellt habe.
Es hat mich emotional
doch sehr mitgenommen.
Ich freue mich wahnsinnig darüber,
dass sie sich tatsächlich überlegen,
in die Schweiz zu kommen.
Wir hätten das vielleicht
wirklich einmal früher machen sollen.
Es ist wirklich eine Nähe entstanden,
die ich so nicht erwartet hätte.
Mit dem Taxi
fahren wir in die Stadt Nanking.
Von da wollen wir mit
dem Schnellzug weiter nach Peking,
wo ich mit meinem langjährigen Fahrer
verabredet bin.
* Lockere, treibende Musik *
Okay. Yeah.
Auf der Fahrt
erreichen mich Nachrichten,
die meine gute Stimmung
gehörig dämpfen.
Die Polizei ist noch mehrmals
bei Ayis Familie aufgetaucht.
Der Grossvater musste sogar
auf den Polizeiposten mitgehen.
Die Familie
ist gekränkt und verunsichert.
Der Gesichtsverlust
steht hier an allervorderster Front:
Sie verlieren jetzt das Gesicht.
"Die Familie, die auf der Insel
so gut situiert ist,
die mit dem Audi zurückkommt
und irgendwie zeigt,
wie grossartig sie ist,
mit denen stimmt vielleicht
doch etwas nicht."
"Sie haben nicht so eine reine Weste,
wie sie vorgeben."
Das ist der Punkt,
vor dem sie Angst haben.
Hast du das Gefühl,
das wird
eure neue Freundschaft belasten?
Das ist wirklich das Traurige.
Das ist das, womit wir immer kämpfen.
Jetzt sind wir
in einem so guten Moment gegangen,
und was muss Ayi jetzt denken?
"Ist es das wert, sich
auf diesen Ausländer einzulassen?"
Wird sie das noch einmal machen?
Vielleicht nicht.
* Chinesische Durchsage *
Mir ist bewusst, dass mein Beruf
es mir nicht einfacher macht,
in China
Freundschaften zu schliessen.
Trotzdem bedeutet dieses Erlebnis
einen Rückschlag für meinen Wunsch,
mich mit dem Land zu versöhnen.
Aber auch das gehört zu meinem Beruf.
Ich schreibe einen Brief
an die lokale Polizei
und erkläre, warum wir da waren.
Ich bitte sie, sich bei der Familie
zu entschuldigen.
Mehr kann ich nicht tun.
Ni hao, Ge.
Aber jetzt freue ich mich
auf meinen Fahrer Ge.
Aha. Ni hao. Danke.
Es kommt noch jemand. Moment.
* Er spricht Mandarin. *
Hello.
Vielen Dank,
dass du dir für uns Zeit nimmst.
Das ist doch selbstverständlich.
Nur die Kamera
macht mich etwas verlegen.- Okay.
Heute ist es das erste Mal,
dass du bestimmst, wohin es geht.
Gut?
- Gut.
* Nachdenkliche Saxofonmusik *
Wir fahren nicht weit,
und schon wieder Polizei.
Wir sind ausgerechnet
ein paar Wochen vor
einer grossen Staatsfeier unterwegs.
Dann sind die Kontrollen
jeweils noch häufiger.
Jetzt spinnen sie voll wegen des ...
- (Mann) Ah, wegen des Kongresses.
Ge und ich haben schon viele
solche Situationen zusammen erlebt.
Mich nervt's trotzdem.
Immer, wenn ich in Peking
zu tun hatte, fuhr Ge mich herum.
Ob ich zu Dissidenten fuhr
oder zu Staatsanlässen:
Ge wusste immer, wo es lang ging.
Obwohl sein Peking-Slang
die Sache nicht einfach macht,
haben wir uns immer gut verstanden.
Das ist noch von damals,
als wir dort waren.
Ja, stimmt.
Das ist nicht von diesem Jahr.
Das ist von 2017. Alle von dir,
auch vom Volkskongress.
Genau.
Erinnerst du dich an den hier?
Das war doch, als euer Schweizer
Präsident hier war, Herr Maurer.
Ueli Maurer.
Das war der Moment, als wir uns
eigentlich verabschiedet hatten.
Da wurde er richtig emotional.
Ich meine, er hat ...
Fünf Jahre
waren wir zusammen unterwegs.
Das war einfach mein Fahrer.
Ich weiss bis heute
nicht viel über ihn.
Und dann hat er gesagt: "Können wir
nicht ein Selfie zusammen machen?"
Er zerdrückte da
schon fast eine Träne.
Da wurde mir bewusst, dass da schon
irgendwie eine Beziehung besteht.
Er kannte uns, und offenbar
mochte er uns und ich ihn auch.
Das war wirklich der Moment,
als ich wusste,
dass ich diesen Mann
noch einmal besuchen wollte.
Seine Familie kennenzulernen,
kam nicht infrage.
Vielleicht will er sie schützen.
Verständlich, gerade
nach unserer letzten Erfahrung.
Seine Frau arbeitet bei
einer wichtigen staatlichen Stelle.
Vielleicht ist das der Grund.
Ge schlägt stattdessen vor,
ihn zum Reiten ans Meer zu begleiten.
Deshalb sind wir unterwegs
zu einer Pferderanch im Norden,
in der Provinz Hebei.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Ge reitet.
Sieht nicht so schön aus.
Wie so häufig in China:
Vorstellung und Realität
klaffen weit auseinander.
Reiten ist in China ein
ungewöhnliches Hobby ohne Tradition.
Die Ranch,
auf die Ge uns führt, ist neu.
Man kann hier Reiten
und Urlaub machen.
Wir wohnen
in dem Gebäude dort drüben.
Es ist noch nicht ganz fertig.
Die Pferde sollen hier
besser sein als anderswo.
Dafür
sind wir immerhin 6 Std. gefahren.
Der Besitzer der Ranch ist gerade
mit 20 seiner besten Pferde
an einem Wettrennen in der Mongolei.
Mir scheint, er setzt darauf,
dass das Verbot von Wetten und
Glückspielen in China bald fällt.
Dann würde der Pferdesport
schnell populär, meint Ge.
Du kommst also wegen der Pferde
und der Infrastruktur hierher,
nicht unbedingt wegen der Natur?
Ja, aber man kann hier
mit dem Pferd im Meer reiten gehen.
Pferde können schwimmen.
Das wusste ich früher nicht.
Aber jetzt weiss ich es.
Reiten im Meer ist
komplett anders als auf dem Land.
Es ist ein Riesenspass.
Das finde ich interessant.
Ich war noch nie am Meer in China.
Obwohl wir in Schanghai,
was "über dem Meer" heisst,
gewohnt haben,
war ich noch nie am Meer.
Ich war fünf Jahre da.
Ich war noch nie am Meer.
In Schanghai
gibt es keinen richtigen Strand.
Die Strände in unmittelbarer Nähe
sind so verschmutzt,
dass man da nicht hingehen kann.
Das ist eigentlich ...
Für mich ist es auch das erste Mal,
dass ich hier in China wirklich
ans Meer, an den Strand gehe.
Und der Strand
sind die Häuser da drüben?
Ja, da, wo es
ein bisschen aussieht wie Rimini.
Das ist der Strand.
Bevor wir uns
auf den Pferderücken schwingen,
treffen wir den Mann,
der Ge zum Reiten gebracht hat.
Er heisst Laotschö
und ist Spirituosenverkäufer.
Wir haben auf dich gewartet.
Guten Tag.
Er hat mir Reiten
und Skifahren beigebracht.
Ich habe ihm Skifahren beigebracht,
doch er ist jetzt besser als ich.
Er ist grossartig.
Ein besonders guter Freund.
Ge ist immer hilfsbereit.
Es ist eher ungewöhnlich in China,
dass Freunde
solche Aktivitäten gemeinsam pflegen.
Arbeit ist angesehen,
Hobbys sind es nicht.
Und die wenige Freizeit
wird meist der Familie gewidmet.
* Fliessende Musik *
Gemeinsam
mit den Angestellten der Ranch
brechen wir auf
zum Schwimmen mit Pferden.
Die Häuser hier
sind bei den Pekingern sehr beliebt.
Ah, hier kaufen Pekinger
die Wohnungen?
Ja, man kann von den Wohnungen aus
das Meer sehen.
Ah. Aha.
Es sind Ferienwohnungen
für den Sommer.
Im Winter kommt meist niemand.
Ui!
* Eindringliche elektronische Musik *
Wow.
Das also ist
mein erstes Stranderlebnis in China.
Ich weiss auch nicht recht.
Es sieht schon nicht so aus,
wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Einmal mehr.
- (Lisa) Warum nicht?
Ja ... Ich weiss auch nicht.
Das ist offensichtlich für Leute
aus Peking ein Naherholungsgebiet,
die mögen das so.
Das ist nicht mein Stil.
Ich würde jetzt niemals
für ein Wochenende hierherfahren.
Aber man kann das
niemandem übelnehmen.
Es gibt Leute, die mögen das. Ja.
* Sie sprechen Mandarin. *
Auch zum Reiten habe ich
ein gespaltenes Verhältnis.
Ich bin mal in der Mongolei geritten
und da vom Pferd gestürzt.
Seither würde ich mich jetzt nicht
gerade einen Pferdeversteher nennen.
Überhaupt verstehe ich im Moment
gerade nicht so viel.
Was ist jetzt der Plan?
* Sie sprechen Mandarin. *
Ich hab ein bisschen Schiss. Der
ist mir schon auf den Fuss getreten.
Ali ist Kasache.
Er ist quasi
auf einem Pferderücken aufgewachsen.
Ob er wohl
der richtige Lehrer für mich ist?
"Ole" heisst stopp.
Ole. Ole.
- Stopp. Ole, stopp.
Was ist das für ein Pferd?
Es ist ein Vollblut aus Australien.
Siegerpferd beim 5'000-m-Rennen.
Ein Champion.
- Champion.
Er will nicht.
- Du musst schnell sein.
Okay.
Ich weiss nicht, ob ich das will.
Es ist gut dressiert.
Sogar Kinder können es reiten.
Okay.
* Freudenruf *
Wunderbar!
Wie ein Mann.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Like a man!
Was ich bei der Vorfreude
aufs Schwimmen nicht mitbekomme:
Es läuft nicht bei allen
so gut wie bei mir.
Man sieht, dass mein neuer Freund
dieses Hobby auch noch nicht
allzu lange betreibt.
Doch dann
reiten wir tatsächlich so weit raus,
dass die Pferde den Boden
unter den Füssen verlieren.
So ganz wohl
ist mir bei der Sache zwar nicht ...
... aber Ge hat recht:
Wenn Pferde schwimmen,
fühlt es sich tatsächlich
ein bisschen an wie Fliegen.
* Schwebende chinesische Musik *
Mir scheint es trotzdem
ein seltsames Hobby zu sein,
das die beiden da betreiben.
Aber was tut man nicht alles
für die Freundschaft?
Warum machst du solche Dinge
mit Ge zusammen?
In China spricht man von Schicksal.
Es fühlt sich an
wie mit einem richtigen Bruder.
Wir haben viel Spass zusammen.
Habt ihre viele solche Freunde?
Oder ist das
eine ganz besondere Freundschaft?
Nicht so viele.
Man sagt in China, man brauche
im Leben nur drei bis fünf,
wenn es richtig gute Freunde sind.
Das reicht.
Wie du und Ge z.B.
Lisa! Essen!
(Ge) Das schmeckt gut.
Sehr lecker.
Wo ist die Sauce?
* Nachdenkliche Saxofonmusik *
(Ali) Zou!
Okay, bye-bye. Xie, xie!
Warum hast du mir nicht
früher erzählt, dass du reitest?
Es ergab sich nie
die Gelegenheit dazu.
Wir hätten das schon früher
ein paar Mal machen sollen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Immer, wenn du ab jetzt
nach China kommst,
gehen wir zusammen reiten.
Bei aller guten Stimmung geht mir
eine Sache nicht aus dem Kopf:
Wie geht es Ayi und ihrer Familie?
Am Montag
fahren wir zurück nach Schanghai.
Wir würden euch dort gerne
zum Essen einladen. Ohne Kamera.
(Lisa) Ist jetzt alles gut?
Ich habe richtig verstanden, oder?
Es geht ihr gut.
Ich habe sie zu Beginn gefragt,
ob alles okay sei,
ob die Polizei wieder
zu ihr nach Hause gekommen sei.
Sie sagte Nein.
Und auch zu ihren Eltern im Dorf
kamen sie nicht mehr.
Ich sagte ihr,
dass es uns wirklich leid tut
und dass du ein Abendessen für alle
organisieren würdest.
Es ist schon gut, glaube ich,
dass wir das tun.
Einfach auch, um zu zeigen,
dass uns etwas daran liegt,
dass es den Leuten auch gut geht.
Das ist eines
der grossen Probleme hier,
dass ich immer
ein schlechtes Gewissen habe,
wenn so etwas passiert,
und man dem gegenüber
eigentlich total hilflos ist.
Du musst immer daran denken,
die Leute zu schützen?
Immer, immer, immer.
Der erste Gedanke ist immer:
"Was kann den Leuten passieren,
weil wir sie interviewt haben?"
Und meistens passiert es eben
genau so, wie es jetzt passiert ist,
dass sie eben erst nachher kommen
und danach
ein ganzer Rattenschwanz kommt,
von dem wir z.T.
gar nichts mitbekommen.
Ist das bei Ge auch so? Hast du da
auch ein schlechtes Gefühl?
Da ist es genau das Gleiche.
Ich weiss nicht,
was da noch passieren kann.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass ...
In Peking hat uns die Polizei
ja angehalten.
Da hat sie auch
Ges Identitätskarte aufgenommen.
Die wissen ganz genau,
dass er mit uns zusammen ist.
Es kann ganz gut sein,
dass sie ihn auch noch aufsuchen.
Ge hat schon erlebt,
dass die Polizei ihn
nach einem Arbeitstag
mit Journalisten befragt hat.
Insgeheim
hatte ich auch schon den Gedanken,
ob er nicht sogar
für den Staat arbeitet.
Aber eigentlich glaube ich das nicht.
Eigentlich glaube ich vielmehr,
dass er genau weiss,
wie viel Nähe er
in seinem Job zulassen darf.
Lamm-Spiesse und Bier.
Sehr gut.
Heute kannst auch mal was trinken.
Ja, wir gehen nicht mehr raus.
Zum ersten Mal kann er heute
mit mir ein Bier trinken.
Was denkt er eigentlich
über unsere Arbeit?
Sind wir für ihn
einfach merkwürdige Typen?
So wie Freunde eben.
Nichts Schlechtes.
Mit anderen Leuten bin ich nicht so.
Wir haben es immer lustig zusammen.
Danke, danke.
Mit anderen
würde ich nicht so viel reden.
(Tian) Sie denken also nicht,
dass diese Gruppe hier Fremde sind?
Nein. Sie sind anders.
Ihr seid anders.
- Das freut mich zu hören.
Das gilt auch für uns.
Deshalb wollte ich ihn
noch einmal sehen.
Oh!
- Oh, oh, oh!
Da brennt noch ...
Ich kann das noch nicht.
* Er spricht Mandarin. *
Man sollte nicht so viel reden.
Der Trick bei dieser Grillade ist,
es laut herauszuschreien!
Ah, okay, okay.
Warum fährst du eigentlich
Journalisten herum?
Du könntest
einen viel einfacheren Job machen.
Das sage ich nicht.
Es ist schwer zu sagen.
Wäre es nicht einfacher,
Touristen herumzufahren?
Er weicht der Frage aus.
Ganbei.
- Ganbei.
Ich habe gelernt,
nicht immer weiter zu bohren.
Chinesen
sind grundsätzlich diskrete Menschen.
V.a. muss ich aber akzeptieren:
Möchte ich Freundschaften in China,
ist es besser, aus Respekt gewisse
politische Themen auszuklammern.
Umso mehr,
wenn ich eine Kamera dabeihabe.
Nur für einen ganz bestimmten Fall
gilt das nicht.
Da geht es nur um Politik.
Ich bin zurück in Schanghai.
Zum Abschluss meiner Reise
suche ich meine Stammbar auf,
das Ying&Yang.
Oft habe ich hier meine
Journalistenkollegen getroffen.
Und immer habe ich
den Hausherrn, Kenny, getroffen.
Hey.
Ladies first. Hi.
Du siehst gut aus. Du auch.
Schön, dich zu sehen.
- Good to see you.
Kenny hat mich manchmal
fast zur Verzweiflung gebracht.
Er war einer der wenigen
chinesischen Bekannten,
mit denen ich über Politik stritt.
Was hier hängt,
ist kein Ethnokitsch.
Diese Reliquien aus der Mao-Zeit
sammelt ein Überzeugter.
Kenny stammt aus Hongkong.
Vor 30 Jahren
ist er nach Schanghai gezogen,
weil ihm Hongkong
nicht kommunistisch genug war.
Hier fühle er sich freier.
Wir hatten viele Diskussionen
und Meinungsverschiedenheiten.
Wie schaffst du es, dass wir trotzdem
immer zurückkommen und dich mögen?
Weil ich schliesslich
meinen Standpunkt vertrete.
Auch über schwierige Themen
zu reden, bedeutet Demokratie.
Ich nehme auf,
was du denkst, was du sagst,
aber ich habe meine Meinung.
Ich habe die chinesische Geschichte
eingehend studiert.
Die kommunistische Partei
ist die einzige,
die dieses Land
mit seiner grossen Zahl an Menschen
über eine so lange Zeit
managen konnte.
Kenny ist schwierig einzuordnen.
Oft weicht er aus,
aber er ist auch
kein unkritischer Vertreter
der kommunistischen Doktrin.
Er zeigt mir einen Wandbehang aus
der Zeit der Viererbande, nach Mao.
Sie war
wegen ihrer Korruption berüchtigt.
Eine Episode der Geschichte,
über die man in China
auch heute noch lieber schweigt.
Ist gestickt.
So etwas sieht man selten.
Menschen, die irgendwann in der
Geschichte eine Rolle gespielt haben,
die nicht so rühmlich war,
darf man nicht mehr zeigen.
Das sind ganz seltene Momente.
Es ist mutig, dass er uns das zeigt.
Eindrücklich.
Das zu zeigen ...
... ist eine grosse Sache.
Während das offizielle China
Geschichtsvergessenheit zelebriert,
ist Kenny
besessen von der Vergangenheit.
Ich habe viel von ihm gelernt,
gleichzeitig aber
auch nie verstanden,
wie man derart blinde Flecken
haben kann.
Etwas vom Wichtigsten hier drin
ist für mich das, was da oben steht.
Ja, Redefreiheit.
Was auch immer du sagen willst,
sag es.
Heutzutage sind die Leute,
wohin sie auch gehen
oder wen sie auch treffen,
immer irgendwie berechnend.
Sie bauen Netzwerke usw.
Sie haben immer eine Absicht.
Aber an dem Ort,
den ich geschaffen habe,
ist man frei,
über alle Themen zu reden.
Und das ist etwas Besonderes
in Schanghai oder China.
Nicht überall
können wir frei reden, oder?
Macht dich das einzigartig hier?
Ich kenne keine anderen Orte.
Ich verstehe das da draussen nicht,
es ändert sich so schnell.
Nichts ist falsch oder richtig,
gut oder schlecht.
Es gibt einfach Unterschiede.
Ich sage nur, Tatsache ist:
China hat sich enorm verbessert,
und jetzt sprechen alle,
auch du, über Redefreiheit.
Es können alle frei reden.
Kontrolle gibt es nur
in einigen schwierigen Gebieten,
weil sie wissen, was für die eigenen
Leute gut ist und was schlecht.
Verstehst du, was ich meine?
Lass uns hier abbrechen.
Zurück auf Feld 1.
Wir werden uns nie einigen.
Aber ich habe mich an diesem Ort
immer wohlgefühlt,
weil es ein Ort ist, an dem die Dis-
kussion stattfindet und weitergeht.
Etwas, was in China immer weniger
selbstverständlich ist.
* Nachdenkliche Saxofonmusik *
Ich bin froh,
dass ich diese Reise gemacht habe.
Ich habe mir die Zeit genommen,
Freundschaften zu pflegen,
zu vertiefen,
und v.a. habe ich die Politik
in den Hintergrund treten lassen.
Es hat mir tatsächlich geholfen,
meinem Wunsch,
mich mit China zu versöhnen,
einen Schritt näher zu kommen.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Daniel McMinn - 2020